a plancha de acusaciones y de reproches
por parte de los líderes de las
instituciones europeas contra Vladimir
Putin y su anuncio de esta mañana en
Moscú por parte de la presente de la
comisión europea Úrsula fonder Legends
los anuncios de hoy de por parte de
Vladimir Putin son una muestra de
debilidad de Rusia frente a Ucrania pero
también un símbolo de que está fallando
la guerra y que está perdiendo
posiciones lo ha dicho luego de una
reunión con la primera ministra
británica listras en los márgenes de la
asamblea general de la ONU que se está
teniendo lugar en Nueva York el jefe de
la diplomacia europea es josep borrell
alertado que tanto los referéndums
ilegales que se van a producir en los
próximos días en el este de Ucrania
también las amenazas por parte de
Vladimir Putin de utilizar armas
nucleares y también está movilización
parcial de tropas significan que la
situación está empeorando que se está
poniendo cada vez más muy grave e
incluso ha alertado de que todas estas
amenazas son una alerta de que ahora
mismo la paz mundial está en peligro
para la Unión Europea los anuncios de
Vladimir Putin de hoy Son una huida a la
desesperada de intentar seguir adelante
a la desesperada y por ello alerta de
que la situación debe calmarse cuanto
antes aún así no descarta nuevas medidas
Como por ejemplo un nuevo paquete de
sanciones sería el octavo ya contra
Rusia